(swoosh)
(bounce)
- What's up Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
I started the Believe
Life series to help us
learn a little bit more about
ourselves, grow personally
and ideally bring some of
what we learn about ourselves
to our business to have more success.
So today we're going to
learn how to take risks.
Rule number three is my
personal favorite and I'd love
to know which one you guys like the best.
Also as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates
with you, please leave it
down in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be
inspired by it as well.
And in you leave it within
the first couple hours
of this video going
live, you have a chance
to win one of two daily prizes.
(upbeat music)
(light jingle)
(swoosh)
- Have you ever heard
that advice to take risks
but you felt like, well I
don't want to take risks,
no one likes risks, right?
No one wants to say when
they wake up in the morning,
"I'm going to take tons of risks today."
Usually risks brings about fear.
We're worried that if we
take a risk, we'll fail,
other people will judge
us, we'll look stupid,
we'll feel uncertained
or unsure of ourselves
and nobody likes those
feelings or those outcomes.
So as much as people say take
risks, it's easy for us to say
"Nah, I'm not into that."
But we also know intellectually
that we can't grow
unless we take more risks.
That your next level of success,
that leap from this level
to that level, there's
going to be risks there.
You know, it's from here to there
and there's that gap in between.
You don't know as you take that leap
if you're going to do
well, that's the risk.
You might fall, you might
fail, you might not do well
but if you're not making those
leaps and taking those steps,
you'll always be stuck
where you were yesterday.
And to grow, we've got
to have a lot of courage
to jump into those risks.
(light jingle)
(swoosh)
- New businesses start out small and so,
it would be very easy for
say, the person who runs
our US books category, to say
"Why are we doing these
experiments with things
"that generated a tiny
bit of revenue last year?
"Why don't we instead focus
those resources and that,
"all that brain power
on the books category
"which is a big business for us."
And instead, that would be a
natural thing to have happen.
But instead, in side Amazon,
when a new business reaches
some small milestone of sales,
email messages go around
and everybody's giving virtual high fives
for reaching that milestone.
And I think it's because we
know from our past experiences
that big things start small.
The biggest oak starts from an acorn
and you've got to reckon...
If you want to do anything
new, you've got to be willing
to let that acorn grow
into a little sappling
and then finally into a
small tree and maybe one day
it'll be a big business on its own.
- Another guy interviews,
a man named Kyle Bass.
Kyle Bass took $30,000,000,
gathered money together,
a lot of money but other people's money,
turned it into 2,000,000,000
in the middle of
the Subprime crisis.
When the whole world
- That's a very
- is blowing up.
- big return.
(Tony laughs)
- You could say that to the ears right?
- [Man Interviewing Tony] Oh my God.
- So I'm like how did you
do this, it's historic.
If there was several books
you read and they open up
the chapter in some of the
most historic books recently,
the gentlemen who wrote,
Fly Boy's also wrote
one of the books and
starts out talking about
Kyle Bass doing this,
this incredible piece.
It's like being there with him.
But the way he did it
was, he risked six cents
to make a dollar, and you
just leverage that up.
So he could be wrong how many
times and still break even?
He could be wrong 15 times and make money.
So what, he's also smart as hell.
He looked at things, he evaluated things,
it's more detailed that
I explained in the book
but the core they all have in common is
they risk for valuable returns.
(stomp)
- I want to make whatever
I'm doing harder.
I know that sounds weird but I'm like,
how could I make my job more difficult?
Because in taking that risk to make it
more difficult, I'll grow.
I'll give you guys an example.
Last weekend, I had
the blessing to keynote
a conference in New Orleans,
some of you all were there.
It was at the Superdome in
New Orleans which holds like
100,000 people but they
kind of spliced it in half
with a curtain and they had 28,
30,000 people in the audience.
This was for the Beachbody
convention and it was a blast.
Now I could get up and
talk to 20,000 people
pretty regularly in my
life, I'm doing it again
next weekend, it's what I
do as a motivational speaker
right, I'm used to doing that.
But I could just go on stage
and do my thing and get off
and that wouldn't be serving
the audience as much.
And so I ask myself, how
can I make this presentation
even harder on me so that I can grow?
So I texted two of my
friends who happened to be
in that organization, Tony
Horton, many of you guys
know he is kind of the
founder and trainer for P90X,
and Chalene Johnson's who does PiYo.
And I texted them both, I
said, "What's your hardest
"exercise move that
people usually can't get?"
Cuz both those people are
going to be at the conference
and this was a lot of their super fans
so I was like let's go.
So Tony told me, he's like,
"The donkey kick is the hardest one."
The donkey kick is
basically you do handstand,
you kick your legs out, you
land back plank position,
you run your leg through like
threading the needle in yoga,
and then you return and
you do a burpee, okay.
And Chalene said, "Well
the hardest one is like
"which cause the Piyo flip," which is like
imagine doing a bridge,
right, but then going
to kind of one arm and it's
like you're doing a bridge
this way and one arm goes that way.
I mean, it's not easy.
So I decided in front of 20,000 people
to do those two moves
back to back in a suit.
So imagine doing a handstand in the suit,
kicking your legs out,
threading the needle,
then flipping over doing
a full extended bridge.
Not easy, but I did it
because it would be hard.
Does that make sense?
Part of the reason I got
better as a speaker is because
I was pushing myself, pushing myself.
I mean, I used to be...
It's very comforting and
easy to give a big speech
and you know, have a transcript
or all these notes to read from.
But I said, "One day I'm going
to be able to get up on stage
"and give a speech with
no notes whatsoever."
Now that's hard, that's not
comforting, it's not easy.
But it's by putting challenges
in front of ourselves that we grow.
And that's part of taking risks.
You know, I will say to people,
"Look if the only challenges
"you're dealing with in life
right now are the ones that
"life dealt you, then you're not
"living a fully conscious life yet."
And what I mean by that is
you're living a life of reaction.
If you're not moving and put...
If you're not moving
towards harder and more
difficult goals, if you're not
giving yourself challenges,
if you're not taking risks
consciously, then you're just
reacting to the world, you're not growing.
And so, challenge yourself.
The next time you're
going to go do something,
your art, your career,
put yourself out there,
try something, make that sales call.
How could you challenge
yourself to make that process
even harder so you get better.
- Both of us right, have given
up a lot for our careers.
And being successful, and
most people don't like it
when I say this, it has costs.
We're not having children
or not having friends
or not having a social life.
And so at some point, you have to decide
whether that cost is worth it or not.
The question isn't
really whether you should
take this risk really is it?
It's what else do I really
want to do in addition to this.
Am I right about that.
- I think so, yeah.
- And I think maybe that's
how I view the risk is
I'm not necessary risking
my company if I decide
to push it further, I'm risking my life.
- It's not just writing a
check, it's I now have to
give like a part of my finger.
- Yeah
- Forever.
- Cause it's going to take
more of your time.
- Forever.
(beat music)
And so that's the tradeoff.
- I truly believe that
whatever you have as a skillset
and if you want to start
a business, it cannot be
outside of the horizon
on where you're at today
and where you want to get to.
So if you've absolutely
come into an industry
and never been exposed
to it, talked to people
in that industry, have any context for it,
have any experience whatsoever,
that is kind of crazy.
I really think it should be about you...
The first leg of the business,
the first testing zone,
the first revenue should
be about 20% further than
where you have been in the past.
So may you've done the
work, you've worked for
another company and
now you want to do that
as your own business.
You've already got that part,
the 20% is really starting the business.
So I call it within the
horizon of where you're at
and where you want to get to.
And every time you get to that new level,
the cool part is the horizon
gets further and further away
and that's how growth happens.
(swoosh)
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you think, what did you learn
from this video that you're
going to apply immediately
somehow to your life or to your business.
Leave it down at the comments
below, I'm really excited
to hear from you and
if you leave a comment
within the first few hours
of this video going live,
you might win one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Mark Drager.
Mark, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and for being
in the book, Your One Word,
and then taking that picture
and posting to Instagram,
I really really appreciate the support man
and thank you for sharing it.
Thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)
(bounce)
- Right now many of you
know, I have a podcast,
about to change that podcast
from something that's been
very successful, you know,
we had top 10 for over
100 weeks in my category, we're
completely changing that up.
So for those who listen
to The Charged Life,
that's going to be
switching up this weekend
to The Brendon Show
and it's completely
different, it's a new format.
We don't need to do it,
the old way worked fine
but part of taking risks
is making yourself evolve,
not being the latecomer
to evolution, right?
So think about how can you
do something different.
I'll give you an example.
When we first started my YouTube
channel back in like 2014
when we really started to
doing weekly YouTube videos,
Travis had this great idea, he said said,
"You know what, what if we did our videos
"in black and white?"
And back then, nobody was
doing videos in black and white
on a weekly basis as part of a show,
certainly not in personal development.
So we did it, it was completely different,
it was a risk for us,
I mean, would it work?
Going from color to black
and white in the modern era?
It did and some of those
videos took off I mean,
1,000,000 views, 2,000,000
views, now some of them
entering their 3,000,000th view.
That happened because we decided
to take a risk and be different.
So how can you be
different in your category,
in your career, in your field of interest.
Whatever you're doing, how
can you purposely choose
to evolve and do something
different cuz that's a risk
and sure, not all risks are
rewarded, but I'll tell you
what's never rewarded, stagnation.
- I think risk is important
for everything company,
I think it is the essence
of entrepreneurship
whether you're the smallest
company in the world
or like Google, the second
largest company in the world
to take smart risks all the time.
I run this experiment
frequently with groups
where I give them two choices,
choice A and choice B.
So choice A is you get
to deliver $1,000,000
of bottom line value to your
company this year guaranteed.
Choice B, you get to
deliver $1,000,000,000
of bottom line value to
your company this year
but only with one chance in 100.
So everyone does the mental math, I say
"Who wants choice A?"
Nobody raises their hand.
"Who wants choice B?"
Everybody raises their hand,
it's got an expected utility,
it's 10 times higher than choice A.
And then I say, "Who here
believes that your boss
"wants you to choose choice B?"
And not a single person in
the room raises their hand.
I mean, it's typically
a large multinationals
who want to be innovative.
And then I say, "You don't
need a lecture on innovation,
"you need a new boss,
you need a new context."
I really think it's the
context that matters.
We all inherently understand
that taking smart risks
is the right thing to do.
Now what counts as smart
and what counts as a risk
is different in different
parts of a company
or companies of different sizes.
You can tolerate a PR fiasco much easier
if you're a tiny company
cuz no one's watching you
than if you're a large
company for example.
So the calculus is
different but the principle
is still the same.
The only way to stay
sharp, to stay growing,
to stay relevant is to take
smart risks all the time.
- [Narrator] When we talk of
(slow piano music)
risks, we are being confronted
every single day
with choices we have to make
that are going to change our life forever.
(slow piano music)
Those that believe in
the power of their dreams
end up manifesting them.
Being brave, taking risks,
following your heart.
A lot of us are comfortable with our life
but through that comfort
comes a lot of anxiety,
a lot of worry, a lot of stress.
Why?
Because we are still living
the same old routine.
Risks are all about expansion,
embracing the new.
So you have to get uncomfortable
to feel at peace.
Risks are
all about uncertainty.
That's why a lot of us,
we stay away from it,
well away from it.
But you see,
we are not afraid of the unknown.
Our projections of the unknown
is what is terrifying.
Just imagine, picture the scenario.
You have 24 hours to live,
what are you going to do?
(ponderous piano music)
(swoosh)